i am therefore delighted that a country with the
political weight and experience of
france is assuming the presidency of the council
at such a delicate moment
because the voice of france speaks loud and clear
and france in europe is at heart
we have  of the world's major projects
the first, of course, is that of the
climate
the commission has made
ambitious detailed proposals to achieve
our goal of 55% reduction
in greenhouse gases by 2030 we want to
do this in an economically efficient
and fair way  a social point of view
we are therefore counting on the
french presidency to advance its
proposals
secondly the digital transition
our common ambition is to
make europe a real
digital power in the world shaped according to
our own rules and our values ​​we
have formulated
ambitious proposals last year our laws on
digital services markets in
order to promote innovation while
putting the major  platforms faced with
their democratic responsibility
I hope and I am sure that the
French presidency before will be quick on
these subjects more generally we
must continue to strengthen our economic model, as
you said,
that of an economic economy that is both
competitive and  social new tribe
working on a new model of
european growth
shape of course by the
digital pact resilience in
line with next generation eu
is based on excellence
sustainability and competitive
european sectors the european union m  among
the first to implement this
historic reform on the
minimum tax
rate as agreed to the os and of and the
govt at i hope that we will reach
an early agreement during the
french presidency another important subject the
management of  borders and the
strengthening of the schengen area our
area of ​​free movement so
we want to restore preserve and
strengthen the openness  e of the
internal borders of the European union to
do this we presented its
proposals of
reform proposals in this direction in December and
I hope that the French presidency
will give the necessary impetus to
progress on this file then we
are to  agreement that we need a real
union of defense and I am delighted that
the French president is committed
to this file I expect a lot from the
discussion that will take place on this subject
in the framework of the summit that we are going to
have  finally in march
i would like to discuss our relations
with africa because it is an
economic and demographic geopolitical space
which will be essential in the world of
tomorrow i am therefore looking forward to discussing the
means of deepening our partnership
during the summit that we  a in brussels
the european union and africa in february